greetings fellow night commanders I'm
bash reverse hey there night commanders
I'm Clara babylegs we're here to show
you my top tips and tricks for leveling
up in knights and Dragons your kingdom
calls tip number one dual notifications
though opt in to receiving notifications
on your phone from the game because once
you're done with everything you're gonna
want to know when to go back in and do
something else the notifications gonna
pop up right in front of your faces tell
you when something is done so you can go
back to playing the game number two max
their buildings every building has a max
limit of how much gold can be earned
test out each building to see how long
it takes to get to that cat so that way
when you return you get the maximum
amount of gold that that building
produces I would say that I can't
believe that you forgot your lines but
I'm I'm not surprised you know what I'm
feeling right now what a lot of judgment
tip number 3 use the quest log it's
amazing it tells you exactly where you
need to be focusing all your time and
effort and it also gives you a quick
teleport to all the quests that you need
to go to without actually looking for
them on the map tip number 4 level up
during battles you can level up in the
middle of a battle going into the next
round your Knights will have full help
you doing what was that nothing is a
monitor right there I can see everything
you're doing how long have you been
doing this while tip number five few
stars you can get few stars for battling
bosses on the epic level but they only
dropped very rarely
Wow tip number six expand your castle
wisely when buying casa responses
therefore the biggest ones first I being
the full swim each one after that will
become progressively more expensive
what's going on he's catching on get the
bag what shhh